[Music]
hello and welcome to drive at the DW car
show coming up a bullet on wheels with
secret agent mystique the Aston Martin
db9 Casa lean and electricity strike the
right balance the Toyota Prius and the
BMW 5-series touring
[Music]
I think our testing Manuel Shaffer notes
that the station wagon version of BMWs
five series has been around for 25 years
now and this is the fifth generation the
designers first revamped the sedan then
the touring car
we're testing the 530 with a 195
kilowatt diesel engine it launches from
0 to 100 and 5.8 seconds BMW says it
consumes 5.1 liters of fuel per 100
kilometers
[Music]
the Front's of the touring car and the
sedan are identical both speak the new
BMW design language visually the
kidney-shaped radiator grilles and the
headlights are a single unit one of the
station wagons innovations is the stub
axle which allows a flat cargo floor
it also widens the cargo area and
increases the maximum cargo weight to
720 kilograms
hi-de-ho Amano says many customers
choose the five touring car over other
station wagons in its segment because of
its two-part hatch that hasn't changed
in the fifth generation so you can open
the top of the tailgate and drop in your
shopping bags easy static so know having
to heave up the weight of the whole
tailgate or wait for it to open
electronically
the standard pneumatic suspension
smoothes the ride on uneven roadways and
the revised station wagon cuts a good
figure overall on country roads but how
does it perform on the highway
[Music]
deffenbaugh to Encanto the 5 Series
Touring Car is often used for long trips
or vacations says he Manoa and BMW had
that in mind when looking for things to
improve first was driver comfort BMW
took a look at the suspension and
decided to replace some parts with
lighter ones and then there's the noise
level in the interior BMW added more
insulation without adding much weight
emmanuel thinks the results are
convincing this generation of the 5
station wagon is noticeably quieter than
its predecessor that makes driving more
pleasant even at high speeds you can
drive several hundred kilometers without
having your head throb from all the
noise when you get out of the car at the
end of your journey cycle time they're
complements by the so loud bar
I know z'ha'dum in o+ oh there's another
thing you Manoa likes you know how when
you set off on a winter morning and it's
cold in the car and your hands get cold
but who wants to wear gloves in the car
of course many manufacturers have
steering wheel heating but where do they
put the control the club for dealing car
title you often spend a long time
looking for it sometimes it's on the
right of the central console sometimes
on the left below the steering wheel
sometimes somewhere else
BMW put the button in the logical place
and the lower middle of the steering
wheel just turn it on and your hands
warm up a simple solution but you have
to think of it first that's practical
for people who often drive different
vehicles plus you don't have to take
your eyes off the road to turn the
heating on or off
[Music]
I listen in mitosis BMW has made lots of
little improvements to the 5-series
station wagon it still isn't the top of
its segment for trunk volume but it does
hold more than its predecessor the 530d
version he tested starts in just under
fifty eight thousand euros in Germany
[Music]
electric cars and plug-in hybrids are
all the rage at the moment but the
Toyota Prius the grandfather of them all
has been out on the road for around 20
years now the Japanese car maker has
regularly updated the technology of
course the current model being sold in
showrooms is the vehicles fourth
generation car tester enos peyto he
explains that the latest Prius comes in
a full hybrid or plug-in version the
latter is more for people who can run a
cable to the car at home in the full
hybrid on the other hand batteries are
charged by the gasoline engine out on
the road or by recovering energy during
braking and engine braking she says eNOS
is taking out the full hybrid self
charging variant of the Prius it's power
is provided by a 1.8 liter gasoline
engine and an electric motor that can
also work independently of its internal
combustion counterpart a secondary
electric motor converts power from the
gas engine into electrical energy stored
in the batteries altogether the system
puts out 90 kilowatts of power the Prius
can hit 100 kilometres an hour from a
standstill in 10.6 seconds and has a top
speed of 180 toh Yoda says it burns just
3.3 liters of fuel per hundred
kilometers
you ready and Tina says that over the
years Toyota has managed to make the
hybrid feel more and more like a
standard internal combustion engine car
drivers can choose different driving
modes among them environmentally
friendly Eco mode a normal mode and a
power mode for when you want a little
more juice the ladder really gives the
car a lot of zip there's also a purely
electric mode for when the car is
traveling at low speeds however the full
hybrid only manages that trick for
around 2 kilometers and that's the
decisive difference between it and the
plug-in version the plug-in has larger
batteries that give it a range in
electric mode of about 50 kilometers
this variant is also 11 centimeters
longer but because the technology takes
up more space Prius plugins have 140
litres less volume in the trunk a
two-port hatch has also been a character
trade in the model for the last two
generations the interior is a study in
contrast and anything but boring the
dashboard display is narrow and sleek a
lot of the important data appears on a
high tech central console
the shifter also has a futuristic look
and feel all these polish surfaces
contribute to the cars modern looks as
heinous but they can also start to look
dusty pretty quickly that's why she
would recommend always carrying a
feather duster onboard just a swipe and
everything gleams again the displays
also make a very modern impression
especially the one up here on the
dashboard which lets you know what's
going on in the car all the time
another modern touch an induction plate
for charging your smartphone without
having to plug it in the most antiquated
feature is the parking brake in the foot
well that's a Tina says electric and
plug-in hybrid cars are really taking
off but for her a full hybrid vehicle
like this one still has a place even
though its range is much more restricted
than a plug-in that's because not
everyone has access to charging cables
at home or just doesn't want to bother
with cables all the time in general she
thinks a key moment for the sector will
come when the batteries can be charged
through induction and you can dispense
with cables altogether
[Music]
following the a-three and a-four out
ia's rolled out a g-tron version a five
a bivalent model that runs mainly on
natural gas but also uses gasoline
outies power to gas initiative helps
make the g-tron models greener than ever
the car maker is producing its own gas
from plant biomass and feeding it into
the natural gas network who Joe has
given its 308 GTI a facelift and
improved technology outside the front
and rear have been redone and the entire
car set lower inside bucket seats and a
new steering wheel stress the cars
sporty side it leaves from 0 to 100 km/h
in just 6 seconds it starts at around
35,000 euros in Germany
[Music]
Zeb's Alcorn Chester rhino Dyson over
says even James Bond doesn't get a new
company car every day and the Austin
Martin DB Elevens predecessor the db9
showed it its platform was developed for
the Vanquish back in 2001 and its
motorization was even older from the era
when Aston Martin belonged to Ford
in the meantime Daimler has bought into
the British car maker and that's fine if
you consider the current AMG GT models
let's see what the DB eleven can do he
says
gets I can see them the official
successor to the db9 is impressive at
first sight and not just one it's sunny
the DB 11 is classically elegant with
proverbial British understatement its
design language will be the basis for
all future Aston Martin models no sills
or spoilers out of consideration for the
neighbors the car is even programmed for
a silent start for the first few metres
the noise flaps in the exhaust remain
closed but later watch out
then the engine roars from all 12
cylinders this gentlemen racecar churns
out four hundred forty-seven kilowatts
and takes just 3.9 seconds to rock it to
100 kilometers an hour it's 700 Newton
meters of torque and top speed of 322
kilometers an hour promise fantastic
if eccentric driving fun in an aesthetic
I know says the Aston Martin gran
turismo interior is classical the
perfect bucket seats and leather seating
make you go ahh when you sit down and
the instruments are very reduced the
central console has five buttons made of
real glass the middle one the ignition
is surrounded by those controlling the
8-speed automatic transmission reinholt
is especially taken with the precise
steering the only thing you can find to
criticize is that there are too few
surfaces to store things the cooperation
between Mercedes and Aston Martin has
paid off the interior feels more modern
than in the DB Elevens predecessors new
are the 12 inch infotainment and digital
instruments but the model hasn't lost
any of its British charm there's top
quality leather wherever you look
the British end of the partnership gets
all the credit for the DB Elevens
handling the car is much faster more
agile than you'd imagine at first sight
overall it seems very different from its
competitors there's none of that Ferrari
melodrama or gut-wrenching Lamborghini
roar and the DB 11 even very high speed
seem routine
[Music]
daddy B edifice country note says the DB
11 definitely has the James Bond feel of
an Aston Martin
it's a lovely GT with performance of a
super sports car and the elegance of a
timeless icon but even when driving at
moderate speeds fuel consumption never
dropped below 14 litres per 100
kilometers
he tells us the DV stands for David
Brown who bought the Aston Martin
company in 1947 in 1963 the db5 became
the first James Bond car and served in
the film's Goldfinger and Thunderball
[Music]
for over 20 years the imposing Grand
Cherokee has been us car maker jeeps
flagship model including mirrors it's 2
meters point 16 wide on German roads it
looks and feels pretty oversized I'm SUV
card system Michelle Assenmacher says
that for Europe the Grand Cherokee has
lots of space comfort and size and short
it's a real American true to the slogan
big is beautiful that Jeep sticks out in
traffic not least because it's 1.8
metres tall a special version released
in honor of the car makers 75th birthday
sports bronze colored decorative
elements 20 inch light alloy rims
emphasize the brawny appearance a 3
liter diesel motor sends the Grand
Cherokee hurtling down the road the back
offers 782 litres of cargo space over a
flat surface with strategically placed
real wood appliques the interior is
pretty elegant a wheelbase of nearly 3
meters translates into lots of room for
passengers and cargo
[Music]
Michelle likes the interior a lot
especially the decorative trim on the
dash which continues on to the door but
she thinks the controls are pretty crude
and simple and don't fit with the Chiefs
imposing appearance
characteristic design elements like the
brand's trademark grill with seven air
intakes make the Grand Cherokee look
like a monster of the road that
impression is emphasized by the
vehicle's chunky massive body design it
looks pretty slow is it what sign up
sign that Michelle says that despite its
two and a half tons the Jeep's v6 diesel
engine makes a nimble and quick its
power is nothing to sneeze at 184
kilowatts and it can hit 100 kilometres
an hour in just over eight seconds Jeep
says the Grand Cherokee burns 7 litres
of fuel over 100 kilometers but in our
test it guzzled over 10 litres in that
distance the cheap reminds Michelle more
of a ship than a car because it's soft
suspension gets you swaying and curves
or over bumps but that's exactly what
makes it a great car for a longer road
trip she says Feisal big lads all flings
typing which brings us back to customers
for this most American of cars longer
travel distances in the US make the
cheeps comfort factor appealing there
my Michelle says in German traffic she
feels more like she's driving a truck
than a car because she's sitting so high
she can practically wave at them but
that makes it harder to track smaller
cars around you that isn't stopping
customers in Europe from buying it the
Grand Cherokee is popular here even 20
years after its launch
[Music]
today car tester Christoph Bauer is
introducing us to a VW sports car that
never got the respect it deserved the
Corrado g60 the Scirocco secured
Volkswagens place in the segment of
affordable sports compact who pays the
Corrado was conceived as its successor
company strategists were demanding lower
fuel consumption and greater comfort at
a more affordable price
in other words better a cheaper the
response was to keep making the Scirocco
and aim the Corrado at the premium end
of the sector minted out as Christoph
tells it Volkswagens development team
got to work on a new sports car in the
mid-1980s under the project name typhoon
harking back to the wind theme behind
names like Scirocco and Passat
eventually they realized the image of a
typhoon as a destructive natural force
was an ideal so the PR department took
the Spanish verb Korea meaning run and
morphed it into Corrado by 1988 he says
they had VW's new sports compact ready
for series production Hana fun fog fog
gate onion stat mid-tempo Gondo a TV had
introduced the Corrado as Volkswagens
first real sports car
the new models interior was adapted
partly from the new Passat 3 while much
of the platform technology was taken
from the second-generation VW golf the
modular design ensured high quality
while keeping assembly cost down dick
the ad says the Corrado buy Volkswagens
this is how we imagine a sports car
[Music]
folks Christophe explains the VW added a
few technological highlights into the
Corrado mix hoping to create a marketing
image of the Corrado as a high-tech
vehicle it boasted the most powerful
engine in VW's history with 1.8 liters
for cylinders and a G ladder
supercharger putting out 160 horsepower
and to keep all four wheels on the
ground it was graced with a retractable
rear spoiler like the new Porsche 911 so
the fastest way to draw admiring glances
was to drive up to the village disco in
a Corrado g60
but christoph isn't sure that was the
precise image VW was aiming for the
apostate but even he's a gutsy Jam
listing at $42,500 the VW corrado cost
about as much as a 5 Series Beemer or a
Mercedes e-class out of reach for most
of its young target buyers when
purchased secondhand many Corrado's were
chewed up by tuners and customizers
widened lowered and souped up
joining Kristoff doesn't think the new
Corrado g60 needed any of that a car
reviewer once wrote between 1500 and
6300 revs and moves ahead at near
relentless speed this was mainly because
the G ladder scroll type supercharger
gave the car plenty of pickup at lower
revs bands at leap from 0 to 100 km/h in
8.3 seconds
topping out at 225 incredibly fast for a
front-wheel drive at that time if
Christoph blatantly over does it the car
might understeer a little but he just
has to ease off the gas to get it back
on track in the curves he's having fun
[Music]
once Christophe knows that at the time
VW's marketing department was very proud
of their new rear spoiler concept it
extends automatically when the speed
hits 120 km/h and when you drive down to
the ice-cream parlor and want to flawed
it a little you can put it up manually
but in other respects the Corrado's look
reflects many elements of VW's design
language in the 1990s clear lines smooth
surfaces and rounded corners a little
boring and Christoph's you optically he
definitely wouldn't call it a milestone
the compact VW corrado made up for its
pedestrian design with extra
practicality the big hatchback allowed
easy access to the spacious cargo space
the rear seats accommodated two adult
passengers and the generous standard
equipment package was unmatched at the
time with ABS power steering sports
seats thermal insulated glass and heated
wing mirrors
[Music]
ace does highlight highlight for
Christoph is this red g60 emblem
indicating the legendary G letter
supercharger under the hood it's a
belt-driven compressor that creates
higher gauge pressure even at low revs
and provides a steady increase in thrust
without the infamous turbo lag the major
downside says Christoph is that if you
floor it with the oil temperature to low
or after a do-it-yourself tuning it can
total the G ladder one reviewer wrote at
the time that it's a lot of fun to drive
but takes a toll on your nerves the
turbocharged 1.8 liter four-cylinder
engine puts out a very respectable 160
horsepower in the late 1980s that was
enough to keep up with most Porsches
Christophe tells us the VW was very
proud of its new showcase car but it
didn't achieve the hope for market
success even if the practical 4-cylinder
aspirated engines and somewhat more
impressive vr6 would have satisfied most
demands only about ninety seven thousand
Corrado's were ever built way too few by
VW standards
in the end the Corrado's high-price were
its doom but not before it had set new
benchmarks as a practical high quality
sports car with robust standard
technology that was nearly unparalleled
at the time kristef winds up by saying
Volkswagen might not have earned much
cash off the Corrado but the boost to
the image of a brand seen as boring and
utilitarian was invaluable
the Corrado showed the world that VW
could be more and compact
high-performance vehicles became a
fixture of the manufacturers model range
special features like the G lauder and
the automatic rear spoiler keep the
Corrado on classic car fan radar even
now he says it was definitely a
milestone in automotive history but a
long time would pass before the Corrado
had an official successor 12 years to be
exact and 2008 Volkswagen finally rolled
out another sports coupe a in the
Corrado spirit but they decided to call
it the new Scirocco
and next time on drive it from zero to
100 three point four seconds the Porsche
911 gt3 and a high-end hybrid crossover
SUV the Lexus NX 300h
[Music]
you